hey guys I'm just okay I'm Laureen and
we are about to go in and play Resident
Evil 7 the lenten demo in VR it's gonna
be great you're gonna love it
please enjoy this course of us please
this is docking here
and you died what no no Amy no no I need
to heat it up we are hiding shut the
[ __ ] up
I don't deserve this
sure or is it yes can you shut up shut
up shut up shut up
no no don't come over here how many
times do I have to tell you god dammit
this house is off-limits this house is
off-limits
well if you let me get out of here
please everyone relax occupy yourselves
well good thing this like not a crazy
woman
the house trying to kill me come on like
that's not hey the controller does it
okay the narrow passage [ __ ] broom
come on where is she huh no no no no no
is this a good hottie I don't know who
you all you have to do is accept or
[ __ ] gift and everyone please be
quiet like the loudest oh [ __ ]
fascinating stupid note where do you
think you're going
that's fine that's fine
so Jess you made it I'm excited you did
it I didn't think I was gonna I was that
scared like it's a waking nightmare like
horror in VR
I don't like Hara everyone knows this
you were so cool calm and collected I'm
well a lot of it kind of like mechanics
felt very familiar like as long as you
knew how this kind of stuff plays out
like we've done this before an outlaw
yeah I feel like because of that I
didn't feel great it was a lot of hide
and seek and I think as long as I was
hiding I felt less like I was gonna be
sort and I didn't get caught but I think
if I had and I thought I was really
close at the end there that would have
been in I would have been out of here
like running yeah big scare though I
think was a really great moment for
everyone who was watching or everyone
but I think overall the experience is
quite solid really like looking forward
to seeing all Resident Evil can offer
the VR experience as well especially
being such a big horror name yeah well
thanks for playing with me no no worries
thanks for watching and I hope you will
enjoy them
[Music]